don't let people kill your joy you'll
find them they will glom onto your shoes
like gum so I would advise starting
today remove people from your life who
make you feel bad about who you are and
what you want to be because there's too
few of us out there unfortunately and so
I want to represent as well and then
we're such a loyal culture too I think
if if they see one of us out there they
say oh look you know he's a Mexican kid
from Chula Vista dammit he can do it I
can do it
go and follow your dream everything is
possible what's that believe nation it's
Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world now this is
a new series on my channel called somos
it means we are in Spanish now I am NOT
a member of the Latin community but I do
believe that you can support one
community without putting another
community down and so my aim with this
series is to shine a light of excellence
on the Latin community and I also want
to give a quick shout-out to Maria
Rodriguez who again gave us some amazing
help in doing some of the research to
make this video happen enjoy alright
let's kick things off with rule number
one ignore the little man was Soledad
O'Brien my parents decided that they
would get married at the end of 1958
when interracial marriage was illegal in
their state Maryland and 16 other states
and they drove to Washington DC and got
hitched and drove back and lived in
Baltimore illegally and when their
friend said whatever you do don't have
kids because biracial kids will not fit
in this world I'm number five of six
my parents were terrible listeners every
step of the way
and from that I've learned do not listen
to other people's take on the life you
should lead my parents were excellent
role models in not listening so I won't
give you any advice today I'll just tell
you what I've seen by not listening you
can figure out what your heart is
telling you to do when I was at Harvard
I was studying English in American
literature I was pre-med but then I
realized that telling stories was my
passion and I switched and started
working at a local TV station it kind of
worked out now I traveled the globe
telling stories not taking advice means
you'll break those boundaries those
walls that exist that make us feel like
we're different from other people we
meet not taking advice means you'll stop
looking for meaning in things that have
no meaning listen some relationships are
not meant to be delete those numbers
from your phone and move on bad things
sometimes happen and they'll continue to
happen until good people get in the way
and I've seen this time and time again
in every single story I've covered be
that good person decide what you want to
be and I'm not talking about a job I'm
talking about the kind of person you
want to be it is up to you and no one
else people can be mean and unfair but
more far far more people are good and
they're generous and they're helpful and
they're hopeful and that means that
you're gonna have to lead with an open
heart and it also means that that little
heart probably is going to get stomped
on a few more times and you'd like but
if you go where your passion and your
heart leads you I guarantee you you will
have incredible experiences I have in
1958 my mother and father were living as
a married couple in Baltimore Maryland
and my mother would tell me the story
about people would spit on them as they
walk down the street together I would
say to her how did you deal with that I
mean why did you do
and she said boo lovey lovey lovey Oh
lovey
we knew America was better than that and
we knew we had to be part of making it
better that's what it was about and she
knew that if you were not too off your
path
anytime someone spit on you literally or
metaphorically you might not get to
where you were trying to go because she
had a dream which was the American dream
and a dream that she would realize as
all coming out of
forty in Cuba and all of her six kids
graduating from Harvard and one of her
grandchildren sitting in this audience
today so please as my mother would
advise you if she were here don't listen
to idiots figure out your dream and be
brave enough to go and live it otherwise
as a friend told me the other day
someone will hire you to help them with
their dream and if that doesn't sound
quite as fulfilling doesn't don't let
people kill your joy you'll find them
they will glom onto your shoes like gum
so I would advise starting today remove
people from your life who make you feel
bad about who you are and what you want
to be don't let people steal your joyful
life you have your lives ahead of you to
do well and do good in this world and to
be great and to be good to others and
find greatness and seek out goodness in
other people because it is all around us
rule number two be a role model with
Mario Lopez I have a pretty good sense
of who I am and it's it's just different
platforms but I'm doing pretty much
delivering the same message I think and
I want to use the opportunity because
there's not too many Latinos out there
especially positive role models to to
set that example I well I don't mind
embracing sort of role model role
because there's too few of us out there
unfortunately and so I want to represent
as well and then we're such a loyal
culture too I think if if they see one
of us out there they say oh look you
know he's a Mexican kid from Chula Vista
damn it he can do it I can do it Yoga
Yoga Yoga minority swing world in
America all right well not in this state
anymore we're not minority we're almost
majority now here yeah we're like
Atwater will multiply it's like giving a
lot of love and honor rule number three
chase your dreams with J Balvin I don't
like the six months ago I had on a plane
crash really yeah in a private plane or
is this yeah you know everybody in that
island like we were the only survivors
from all the airplane crashes that
happened over there
Wow where was this that was vamos
Bahamas yeah Bahamas
how many people on the plane where we
were six and you all survived yes and
not even one scratch and everybody died
last night you know when I got out from
the plane you know the plane was there
caught up on fire and and we all were
alive and I was like why so when I
started like running to the FBO I was
like I told them a story they were like
you're lucky because everybody died you
know like the last seven a plane crashes
that they had there everybody died Wow
so there's no there's no there's no
coincidence the thing life is perfect
and so I remember that Pharrell Williams
called me that day and it was like
listen there's no life has no mistakes
mmm it's perfect and you're here because
of reason so he was like what are the
chances to be alive and work from our
airplane crash so that's when I was like
hmm okay so I got out I still have
something to do in this world and and I
always knew it but I was new but now I'm
like reassured that you know the message
that I have to send the people is like
you got a dream no you need it's reason
a reason why you know to get up in the
morning and say okay I'm gonna get this
this is what I want to and dreams are
beautiful man because they keep your
they keep you with hope and with when
there's hope there's a future mm-hmm and
that's you know I think that's the
message you know music it's just the way
I can get to the people and and and and
and tell the story yeah you know like go
and follow your dream everything is
possible you know and the good thing
about dreamers is like there you know
there's no end you know you can dream as
long as you want yeah once you achieve
one dream give another one another one
another one and it doesn't matter how
big they are if there's four small
dreams or big dreams their dreams and
that's pretty much rule number four love
what you do with Ozuna
Asuma meant FSL decir que voy hacer de
forme de los angelitos repeated comment
a que yo yourself or how I said in Walla
Walla red drink a moment II remote relay
photo algún way only say Apple que todo
lo que yo - ay que pasar
yes sir para el asalto locator fastened
om dia yourself continued to again come
in our appear for us from dudeney again
my you are forget occult to attack etc
karim totally separate all necessary
cell phone you are see dark again di
aprendido cell lead
yo yo quisiera Mon Calamari my yoga API
case in me yeah in a Corral taken a bomb
will turn the bomb will tell pocoyo
quiero so he can hand out
[Applause]
though the pendant bully coefficient
primont Acapulco Celente my quiere yo
quiero Seguin kappa [ __ ] face Sudan
they called me Iowa sorry I'll go okay
you looking for in your letting one more
important in here okay me Ronnie oh look
at yo salient Diego nothing one more
right dollar OD I want they don't know
my question I gonna see how your
paternity Mayo I let them inside cool
you go color more of an open your
emotion
rule number five
put your customers first with Maria
Martinez but of course as your number of
customers grows so quickly you mentioned
you're in hyper growth and for many
businesses here that may be in hyper
growth how do you continue to keep that
service level feeling like it's personal
and relevant and absolutely specific to
the customer needs at a point in time
but at a scale that you mentioned you've
180,000 customers and presumably that's
growing and how do you manage to give
people the right service at the right
time well I think part of it is we
create a lot of products that that you
know that help you know different ways
to advise her customers and the like
different services we're always thinking
about services as a product as well to
make sure that we do that but I if I had
to pick one thing I would say is the
culture of the team right what really
hard on the culture of the team making
sure that they they know that the
customer comes first
yep and that we're always innovating on
how we serve them better we talked about
technology we talked about products all
that but at the end of the day it's
about taking care of our customers right
and we do that and I I personally as a
leader of the organization take that as
a big responsibility
yeah to make sure that I'm always so for
example just to give you an example this
morning as I was in at the airport I was
evening out in the US and someone you
know tweeted something about that day we
were not being responsive right so that
happens and you know every every once in
a while more than often I am pulling
that person personally oh right mazing
to show the team yeah
that first the customer apologize what
went wrong whatever but to show the team
that we all need to be there for our
customers and creating that that true
culture of customer success I think it's
the number one thing that I would for
this rule number six show the world your
greatness with Gustavo Santo liya all of
this is so interesting to me because you
know you forgive me because I didn't
know a lot about your career what I knew
you as was the Oscar winner got of
course he does film soundtracks right so
I mean it was in the 2000s you start
becoming known for your film scores
various awards to Oscars Brokeback
Mountain a novel a Golden Globe and a
BAFTA you know where the Brokeback
Mountain score is beautiful thing but
but it's interesting listening to you
talk now and I almost feel like the
Oscar winner guy are you comfortable
with being the establishment guy who
writes these soundtracks well I mean I'm
not the establishment guy never been I
don't know if I ever will be not because
of I don't want to but because it's the
nature of what I do or how I move I do
so many things for a while it was really
funny because people didn't know that
the same guy that was on stage playing
with bajofondo was the same guy that won
the Oscar that was the same guy that
produced a Kiwanis record right you know
people dressed just you know they had
connect the dots now more people know
that this the same person that you know
they're all all these things but I I
think you know the reason I wanted to
produce and going back to the first of
your questions all this was because I
felt that in Latin America we had the
potential and and we have certainly the
weight the artistic weight sometimes
even more so than in the angular world
of great musicians and great talent that
didn't have the chance to make the
records that were made here in the
United States or or in England and my
task was to try to show the world that
you know we had groups that were as good
you know one of the groups that I always
talk about is café tacuba which I
believe is right up there with Radiohead
with Bjork they don't have anything to
envy I mean creativity in what they do
the quality of
they though and so on and I felt that we
we help that happen we somehow helped
create this important movement of rockin
Hispaniola rule number seven is be
relentless with Keylor Navas you mucho
trabajo de mucho de si todo lo que
trabaja da sido para esto por fin el
momento que las cosas Sandra Alice -
Mary why Olivia trabajo mucho they could
use a pequeño the Ateneo Tranio Yagami
cos mi cuenta de mercy entries that's
all yeah like it's Thomas conch a learn
a sport already is your respond Els your
well those policies i okay Casey Impreza
make a simple attend yarmulke Reza and
it okay cuando pienso has a meaning
which has causes Capasso me a las fallas
no Co fuzzy less pero este mundo now
Simplot any offers as para allá de
atlanta yo creo que de got a keeper
amateur alia said Chris Capel it means
I'm in total a tantor's Nino's in Costa
Rica into the RO sitios porque tu mundo
Sueno con for Harold Real Madrid the
toes New York at the elephant [ __ ] case
a puede si si use it whatõs para para
que lucha maracas cranky when a king
cosas que que a grandparent and turkeys
are so swollen 3 el corazon e hill wagon
come control Organa del mundo porque si
you know the pony a look on CD yes I
okay Mahalo Yami Elsevier key
controversy simply just for the lintel
of Kosala movie and rule number eight
the last time before very special bonus
clip with Beyonce is make it happen with
Anthony Gonzales music's occurs
great-great-grandfather none of them
under
I'm supposed to play music alright
losing that
you mind it's so good
accidentally ends up in the land of the
dead in the heartwarming new Pixar movie
called cocoa he is voiced by 13 year-old
Anthony Gonzales who joins us this
morning please welcome Anthony thank you
saw this movie last week I'm going to
say it as my brand-new favorite I laugh
I cried you are so good in this your
baby is a singer in this and you've been
a little entertainer singing with your
brothers and since you were four yeah I
gotcha BAM um well so um it all started
with my sister my sisters and my
brothers they started singing and
dancing and leprosy Talavera which is in
LA and they would do like street
performance and they would do like a big
show
and then I would just like look up to
them and I would think to myself wow
they're having so much fun I want to do
that too and when I started singing at
the age of four I I knew that I wanted
to do it for the rest of my life because
it was so much fun oh my gosh you're so
good in it we don't want to give too
much away but there's this one song you
step out on the stage I wanted more of
the music and look I happen to have a
coco guitar right here oh wow how does
it go what color what color is the sky I
mean would you tell me that it's red I'm
mo I'm mo where should I put my shoes
I'm mo Dino mode you say put them on
your head
I'm mo hood I'm a moon and it also
speaks to remembering those who have
passed and the celebrations we'll call
it of the Day of the Dead in Mexico
which you celebrate yes why do you think
it's so important to remember our family
members who have passed well because
they were the ones who like formed who
we are now like for example me like my
grandfather passed away at the age of
six and he was very important to me and
special to me because he supported me in
my music career and I don't think I'd be
here without his support and he always
encouraged me to do like things I never
thought I would do and just when I
celebrate the Day of the Dead it's a
time where I can be with him again and
connect with him and that's why I love
this joyful celebration and that's
really what it is it teaches us so much
there's adventure which we love yes and
it really does bring you to tears so
when you watched it back could you
believe it so you grew up watching
Disney
and now here you are you're going to be
immortalized forever we all remember you
in this world forever game how does all
of this feel I mean it just feels
incredible
it feels amazing because like I grew up
just watching these movies I grew up
like watching toy story I have like the
woody toy and I have like a buzz light
your blanket that says my name and I
actually like never thought I'd be in a
Disney Pixar movie at this age
I've got a very special bonus clip with
Beyonce that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that I would love to
know what do you guys think of the
series it's still relatively new for us
we're still testing and trying to
improve so I would love to get your
feedback if there's anything that you
think we can do to improve it any people
that you want to see profiled any
messages that you feel should be coming
through please leave it down the
comments below we're gonna pay attention
to every comment that comes in thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you soon enjoy the
bonus clip and again thank you thank you
thank you so much to Maria Rodriguez for
your help in creating this video welcome
back guys I hope that you enjoyed this
month's episode of somos I think it's
the best series out there right now on
YouTube highlighting Latino and Hispanic
influencers around the world the clip
that made the most impact on me this
month was Mario Lopez big shout out to
Mario not only am i a big fan because I
was such a Saved by the Bell
fan as a kid growing up my favorite
television show for sure
I see consistently in every interview
that I watched he talks about creating
opportunities for other Latinos that are
underrepresented in you know in the
entertainment industry every single
person that we highlighted this month in
them being successful and excellent in
what they are doing in their industry
they are opening doors for those who are
coming after them and that's amazing
I love it and I hope that you loved it
too see you next month and salud
[Applause]
the whole idea of be good has been to
create long term ties with organizations
here that are making a real difference
in the lives of kids
Beyonce never forgets these young people
and in every city
she's always reached out
like to pray for you their families I
think you've got some a new truck moving
a poor kid from South Central and
because you believe in yourself you'll
get what you're told you can follow your
dreams and do whatever you want
life use it perform know that you're
worth it and
to be what I read as you
/ be super confident
be good that's what I thank you guys for
coming I'm so proud of you inspire me
and so many other people and hopefully
people will see that you work so hard
and they're so positive and will want to
do the same thing it means hope
it reads a second chance it means a
bigger dream I actually might become
whatever it is that I'm not to be
Oh 1 1 0 1 words long media the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be to
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]